hi everyone welcome back to my channel
and look who i have here with me
hi zuma it's hazley so some of you might
recognize him from my previous workout
video
so hazley are we excited yes
so you might be wondering what language
is he speaking right
[Laughter]
is speaking in malay that's because we
just launched our new youtube channel
called
seahawk sophmore okay so the channel is
based on our own mother tongue
in malay language so be sure to check
out the channel and subscribe to our
channel
what will we be doing today okay
snack away correct when you're bored
doing nothing at home what would you do
reach for a snack and start eating
it
yup that's right i'm sure most of you
have been snacking on lots of junks and
some of you have even
messaged us telling us that you have
gained a lot of weight
so today we want to share with you three
of our favorite
healthy snack recipes which you can make
at home
and not feel guilty when you snack away
the first recipe is my favorite banana
oat muffins
chocolate glove smoothie and the final
recipe
look at this chia pudding topped with
lots of nuts and fruits so all these
recipes are really simple you only need
about five to eight
ingredients for each recipe
again nope you don't need to know how to
cook because literally
all you need to do is put them all
together bake them
or leave them to chill in the fridge
that simple butter
for the banana oat muffin you'll need
one and a half cups of oats
half a cup of greek yogurt two to three
bananas
two eggs two tablespoons of honey or
maple syrup
quarter cup of crushed walnuts about 2
tablespoons of cranberries
and 1 teaspoon of baking soda that
simple
so we want to start by blending the
rolled oats
blend it until it's fine and flour like
in a small bowl
mix together the oats as well as the
baking soda
set it aside in a large bowl mash the
bananas
then mix in two eggs and beat
until they are even next stir in the
greek yogurt
and mix well
now stir in the oat mixture if you want
it to be sweeter you can choose to mix
in a little bit of honey or maple syrup
mix until all the ingredients are well
combined
finally stir in the dried cranberries
and also walnuts continue to mix until
you have a consistent batter
now let's transfer the batter evenly
into 8 muffin cups
[Music]
top it up with some walnuts
[Music]
bake it in the oven for about 15 minutes
or until the muffins are fully cooked
through
now allow them to cool down before
removing them from the cups
look at this hazy look at that oh
wow it's so simple only eight
ingredients and it's so flavorful and
delicious
[Music]
i really like the natural sweetness from
the bananas
and i really like the texture
it's firm but yet it's still moist
inside
is it delicious
and at the same time you get the crunchy
texture from the walnuts as well
so this is my favorite snack recipe and
i
make them very often some of you might
have seen it on my instagram
i make this very often i like to have it
either at home or sometimes i will bring
it out with me and have it as my
post-workout snack as well
that's right you can also serve this
with tea or coffee
so be sure to try this recipe out okay
so hazy i am so excited for your next
recipe
can you share more with us
what ingredients will we need to make
this awesome smoothie
[Applause]
[Laughter]
here you have it so simple
smells good yeah i like the chocolate
texture
and of course i'm going to try it okay
very low
this is so good and this is even perfect
as a quick breakfast and even as a
post-workout meal isn't it
anti-oxidant it's delicious you have to
try it
okay joanna
this is actually my favorite dessert
okay and this dessert is
healthy it's chia pudding topped with
any favorite fruits of your choice or
even dried nuts and fruits
and again really simple guess how many
ingredients do we need
only five ingredients yep that's right
yes so to make the base of this chia
pudding you'll need quarter cup of chia
seeds
one cup of milk of your choice one
teaspoon of maple syrup or honey
one banana and two tablespoons of peanut
butter
again the steps are really simple i
think you guys know by now that we like
to keep our ingredients really simple
and healthy so in a bowl mash the banana
then mix in the rest of the ingredients
mix until all the ingredients are well
combined
then transfer the mixture into two cups
set it in the fridge for about 20 to 30
minutes until the chia pudding is firm
then top it up with any fruits and nuts
of your choice i'm adding a little bit
of fresh blueberries
with cranberries as well as almonds it
is
that simple wow
[Music]
yes you can there you go yeah
so what i really like about this is that
it's a really healthy dessert
which you can make it for your family
members and you can even
make it for a party so people can have
this
without feeling guilty because it's all
made with
super food and real ingredients is it
good
um
yes the peanut butter i love the nutty
taste in it and i love
the banana taste in it as well and the
great thing about chia pudding is that
you can
choose any other ingredients of your
choice and make lots of different
versions so you will not get bored
yes which means it is very good for your
digestion so
having chia regularly will help with
your digestion as well
so these are three really simple healthy
snacks which you should try at home yep
so aim to consume more whole foods that
would be good for your body okay and you
won't feel so guilty afterwards
try all these recipes out let us know in
the comment section below how you like
them
and don't forget to share your pictures
tag us at joanna's
official and at hasley bajilli and also
follow our new channel channel youtube
more than jugger ig kami at
sihatsukumo.tv
that's right go and check it out okay
and don't forget to also
hit the subscribe button if you haven't
yet done it check out a lot more workout
videos
fitness tips and also more healthy
recipes on my youtube channel and thank
you so much
i hope everybody had fun we will see you
next time bye